Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Dr. Karat. Ich bin auch Disastersfühler als Erster Erlstätik und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Ja.
Okay. Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren bitte?
Ja, ich heiße Röckemann.
Röckemann. Vorname Petra.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Namen bestaubieren?
Ja, der Nachname ist Erl, dann Ö, CK, E, M, A, N, N. Röckemann.
Röckemann.
Und?
Nachname.
Das ist der Nachname.
Röckemann.
Der Vorname ist Petra. P-E-T-R-A.
Petra.
Danke schön. Herr Södermann.
Frau Röckemann.
Ah, Frau Röckemann.
Petra ist eine Frau.
Ja, Frau Röckemann.
Röckemann.
Jetzt möchte ich ganz schnell allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
64.
Und wann sind Sie genannt geworden?
Am 3. Januar 1958.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,66 m.
Und wie schnell sind Sie?
60 Filo.
Okay.
Frau Röckemann.
Was für Geschmacken haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich habe ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen seit einem Tag.
Und die werden immer schlimmer.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Die begannen so in der Mitte vom Bauch, so um den Bauchnabel herum.
Aber jetzt sind Sie ein bisschen mehr im rechten Bauch.
Ein bisschen so zwischen dem Rippenbogen.
Und da so rechts rüberziehen Sie.
Aber sind auch immer noch in der Mitte, aber mehr rechts.
Ja, okay.
Sind die Schmerzen da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die kommen und gehen so, die sind so wellenförmig.
Okay.
Haben die Schmerzen plötzlich begonnen?
Ja, die fingen langsam an.
Das war nicht plötzlich, langsam, aber sie wurden dann immer schlimmer.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz,
gerade von 1 bis 10, 1 ist sehr leicht und 10 ist sehr stark.
Ja, ich würde sagen, die sind ja so wellenförmig.
Wenn die Welle vorbei ist, vielleicht 5,
aber wenn der Schmerz richtig kommt, würde ich sagen bis 8.
5 bis 8.
Ja, okay.
Verstanden die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nee, die sind im Bauch.
Okay.
Gibt es Faktoren, die die Schmerzen hindern oder beistärken?
Ob sie sich verstärken durch irgendetwas?
Ja, gibt es Faktoren, die die Schmerzen hindern oder beistärken?
Also wenn ich auf den Bauch drauf drücke, tut es mehr weh.
Das ist schlimmer.
Und ich setze mich immer gerne so ein bisschen so vorne geboichtin
oder ich lege mich auch so fahr, dann ist es am besten.
Frau Rosemann, sind Sie übel?
Ist Ihnen übel? Ja.
Hier ist übel.
Das nimmt auch zu, das wird schlimmer mit der Übelkeit
und ich habe auch etwas so Brechreiz, aber ich habe noch nicht erbrochen.
Frau Rosemann, hatten Sie so etwas von einem neuen Freihärm?
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Frau Rosemann, haben Sie in nächster Gestern etwas auffälliges gegessen?
Nee.
Ich habe in den letzten Wochen sowieso nicht so einen guten Appetit.
Also ich kann nicht mehr so viel essen.
Aber ich habe nichts auffälliges gegessen.
Seit letztern, jester Woche haben Sie schlechte Appetit.
Schon einige Wochen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube, ich habe kein Fieber.
Haben Sie Duschwein oder Verstopfung?
Verstopfung, ich kann in den letzten Tagen, wie sonst,
kann ich immer jeden Tag, habe ich immer Stuhlgang,
aber seit zwei Tagen habe ich keinen Stuhlgang mehr.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost und ein Langschweiß?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Manchmal schwitze ich nachts etwas, aber das habe ich immer schon etwas gehabt.
Das ist jetzt nichts Neues, nichts Besonderes.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Beim Schlafen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich kann nicht ganz gut schlafen.
Nur jetzt seit gestern nicht, seitdem ich die Bauspräzen habe.
Da war die letzte Nacht nicht so gut.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit umgeworft schreiendert?
Ja, ich habe abgenommen.
Ich habe so fünf Kilo abgenommen in zwei Monaten.
Ich bin jetzt noch in der Sitzung.
Haben Sie noch weitere Symptome der Beschwerden?
Nein, jetzt tut das gerade wieder so stark weh.
Jetzt kommt wieder so eine Welle, wo es gar nicht so gut ist.
Aber das geht gleich wieder vorbei, wird gleich wieder etwas besser.
Aber sonst habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich kann nicht so gut mehr auf Toilette gehen.
Und der Stuhlgang, der war auch immer so nicht mehr so richtig
und war auch immer so ein bisschen schleim dabei.
Haben Sie Blut in Stuhl gemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, wegen Corona war ich immer zu Hause.
Jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie an krönchen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe hohe Blutdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Und da nehme ich ein Medikament.
Aber ich nehme nur eine Tablette.
Welche Tablette nehmen Sie?
Das steht drauf.
Kan-de-Satan, 8.
Da muss ich morgens eine Tablette nehmen.
8 mg.
Nur morgens.
Da steht drauf 8 mg.
Und morgens?
Ja.
Haben Sie noch andere krönchen Erkrankungen?
Nein, sonst geht es mir eigentlich gut.
Hatten Sie in der Vergangenheit schwere oder böse Artige Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, nur diese Tablette für den Blutdruck.
Hatten Sie gegen aktuelle Schmerzen Medikamente ein?
Nein, habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Schragwürzelt man, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nach einer Schwangerschaft hatte ich mal eine Ausschabung.
Das ist aber schon 30 Jahre her.
Sonst habe ich bisher keine Operation gehabt.
Nach einer Schwangerschaft?
Ich habe 3 Kinder.
36, 33 und 30.
Nach dem letzten Kind hatte ich eine Ausschabung.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Das haben Sie nach einer Schwangerschaft gehabt?
Eine Ausschabung.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das im Fachbegriff heißt.
Aus der Gebärmut hat etwas Gewebe entnommen.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Nein, nein.
Oder Unfärbtechnik?
Ich vertrage alles.
Alles essen sonst bis auf den Appetit,
der jetzt in letzter Zeit etwas schlechter geworden ist.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Impfstatus?
Was meinen Sie jetzt?
Welche Impfung?
Haben Sie alle Impfungen gegen Kindererkrankungen bekommen?
Ich habe Impfungen gegen Wundstarkrampf bekommen.
Difterie und Keuchusten.
Das habe ich beim Hausarzt gekriegt.
Ich habe eine Grippeimpfung gemacht.
Ich habe auch schon 3 Impfungen gegen Corona gemacht.
Rauchen Sie Zigaretten?
Ja, ich rauche.
10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Das ist schon seit 40 Jahren.
Schenken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends zum Abendbrot.
Ich trinke in der Regel Einglaswein.
Ich muss raus.
Auch diese Pfadgestellen nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Meine Kinder sind gesund.
Meine Mutter ist mit 60 Jahren gestorben.
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Da war er 78.
Da hatte er einen Herzinfarkt.
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Meine Kinder sind gesund.
Ich werde eine Geschwister.
Ich bin aus Berlin, Berlin.
Ich bin seit einem halben Jahr in Rente.
Ich war vorher Busfahrerin.
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, mein Mann lebt und ist gesund.
Nehmen Sie zusammen?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder, wie gesagt.
Ja, sonst ist eigentlich alles gut, bis auf meine Schmerzen.
Okay, klar, Herr Sermann.
Jetzt bin ich fertig.
Was ist noch etwas, was Sie mir sagen möchten?
Was kann das sein?
Nein, das macht mir Sorge, was diese Bauchschmerzen, was denken Sie?
Ich verstehe, Sie Sermann, Sie sich Sorge machen, aber wir müssen erstmal ein paar Unterwirkungen machen.
Dann möchte ich schon alles in die Hand.
Ja, okay.
Gut, alles klar.
Dann machen Sie wieder fünf Minuten?
Okay.
Okay, bis gleich.
Geht es?
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberer.
Ich möchte Ihnen über eine Patientin berichten.
Haben Sie kurz gleich?
Ja, habe ich.
Die Patientin heißt Petra Rosemann, 64 Jahre alt,
166 cm groß, 60 kg schwer.
Die Patientin stellte sich bei uns wegen provisierter
wellenklöniger Bauchschmerzen seit gestern vor.
Die Schmerzen am Anfang, die Schmerzen seien am Anfang Bauchmitte,
aber im Laufe der Zeit hätten sie die Rechten unter Bauch gezogen.
Ja.
Die Schmerzen seien langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen tendenziert, wie dabei fünf bis acht.
Die Schmerzen würden nicht ausstallen.
Okay.
Die Patientin richtete, dass die Schmerzen beim Vorlegen besser seien.
Sie außerdem klackte sie über Lausia.
Die Frage nach Vomitus wurde verneinzt.
Ja.
Und die haben keine Schiebe und Schütterprost.
Die vegetative Anmese erhielt die Obstifastion seit zwei Tagen in Appetenz seit einigen Wochen.
Und Gewichtsverdurch von fünf Kilogramm innerhalb zwei Monaten.
Sie leiden an Artillerikartoni seit zehn Jahren,
da ging neben sie Kantisartan acht Kilogramm morgens.
Ja.
Und in Anforderungen sei nach einer Schadenschaft vor drei Jahren Ausscharbung.
Vor 30 Jahren.
Ausscharbung ist eine Abrasio.
Sie haben keine Allergien.
Die Impfstatus sei vollständig.
Sie ist auch, sind Zigaretten am Tag seit 40 Jahren.
Trinke Alkohol, trinke Einglas hier am Tag.
Wein.
Am Tag jeden Abend.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneinzt.
Ja.
Ist die Papierin den noch berufstätig?
Nein, sie ist Landmärin.
Sie ist Landmärin.
Okay.
Dafür arbeitete er als Busfahrerin.
Was war der letzte Stuhlgang?
Das habe ich eben nicht verstanden.
Wann hatte die Patientin den letzten Stuhlgang?
Nächste Stuhlgang war vor zwei Tagen.
Vor zwei Tagen.
Ist das normal bei der Patientin?
Hat sie immer alle zwei Tage nur Stuhlgang oder ist das ungewöhnlich?
Die Patientin hat gesagt,
das ist unanomal.
Hat wahrscheinlich sonst jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Und jetzt ist der Stuhlgang weg.
Okay.
Ja.
Und was denken Sie, Herr Kollege?
Was könnte das sein?
Die bisherigen anhand des deutschen Angaben,
die Menschen auf der Pandy City,
das bin ich,
aber wir müssen,
als Differenz in Diagnose,
kommen,
die Vertributis oder
Kolonkarstinom auch in Betracht.
Besonders vor dem Hintergrund einer Gewichtsabnahme.
Sie sagten doch 5 Kilo Gewichtsabnahme.
Sprich nicht unbedingt für eine Appendicitis,
wahrscheinlich doch eher vielleicht Richtung Kolonprozess.
Mal wir jetzt doch eventuell Hinweise auf einen Subilius
oder Ilius haben.
Seit zwei Tagen keinen Stuhlgang,
wellenförmiger Schmerz und Gewichtsabnahme.
Das ist ja, muss man fast dran denken.
Richtig.
Ja.
Gut.
Was würden Sie noch Differenzialdiagnostisch sagen?
Also einmal, ich denke Richtung Kolonprozess,
Kolon, oder stilisierender Prozess in Kolon.
Es kann ja auch ein zündlicher Prozess sein.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Ja.
Die Patentin ist alt,
aber vielleicht kron.
Wie gesagt, Kolonkarstinom.
Eventuell muss man noch in einem Prozess der rechten Agnexe,
O-Variall-Prozess, eventuell.
Aber es ist, glaube ich, von der Wahrscheinlichkeit her
vielleicht nicht so gut.
Hatte die Patientin schon Vorsorgeuntersuchungen,
wissen Sie das?
Hat sie schon mal eine Kuloscopie gehabt, eine Darmspiegelung?
Nein.
Ich umstelle.
In welche Richtung wollen Sie jetzt die Untersuchungen machen?
Was für eine Diagnose-Strategie haben Sie vorzuschlagen?
Erstmal erst die Linie,
muss ich körperlich untersuchen.
Okay.
Danach die Abnehmen und den Fall mit Zirkons überprüfen.
Dann die Bewerber überprüfen.
Dann Ultrasaal-Untersuchung ist erfolgreich aus meiner Sicht.
Also körperliche Untersuchung, einschließlich rektale Untersuchung.
Ganz wichtig bei dem klinischen Bild, Richtung Ilius.
Zu gucken ist die rektale Ampoulelea.
So eine Skopie Sie meinen Sie?
Genau.
Dann Sonografie des Abdomens, Labor-Untersuchung.
Zu gucken, wie die Entzündungszeichen sind,
ob sie Leukozytten hat, ob sie eine Anämie hat.
Eine wichtige Leitplanke ist die Vorgeschichte mit der Gewichtsabnahme.
Sie hat weniger Appetit gehabt, haben Sie berichtet.
Gibt es in der Familie eine Auffälligkeit,
familiäre Vorgeschichten,
gibt es dort Karzinome im Kolonbereich?
Ja, die Mutter sei an Kolonkarzinome gestorben.
In welchem Alter, wissen Sie das?
60 Jahre alt.
Da muss man schon mal dran denken,
dass das durchaus eine gewisse Risikokonstellation ist im familiären Bereich.
Denetische Perandavon.
Okay.
Also, ich denke, wie gesagt, Appendicitis würde ich jetzt als Erstes nicht so dran denken,
sondern eher vor der Vorgeschichte, so wie der Schmerz anfing,
natürlich auch eine Appendicitis.
Dann dieser stark wellenförmige Schmerz mit Gewichtsabnahme in den letzten Wochen.
Gewichtsabnahme, ich habe gedacht, wenig.
5 kg.
Ja.
Die meisten legen in dem Alter leider etwas an Gewicht immer zu.
Da ist schon 5 kg Gewichtsabnahme,
die die Patientin nicht so unbedingt erklären kann.
Müssen Sie sonst fragen,
haben Sie eine spezielle Diät eingehalten,
wollten Sie Gewicht abnehmen?
Dann ist das vielleicht noch etwas anders,
dass Sie sagt, ich habe jetzt seit 2 Monaten eine Diät,
wo ich Gewicht abnehmen will.
Aber 5 kg sind da schon bedenken wert.
Gut.
Mir kam es bewusst darauf an,
dass Sie unterscheiden.
Ich habe gesagt, ich heiße, sind wir noch da?
Ja.
Der Name Röckermann ist gut, dass Sie gesagt haben,
bitte Buch stabilieren.
Und ich habe extra gesagt Petra,
wenn ich natürlich vor Ihnen sitze,
und ich bin eine Frau Petra und Peter,
Peter ist ein männlicher Vorname in Deutschland
und Petra ein weiblicher Vorname.
Da war ich jetzt etwas gemein zu Ihnen.
Entschuldigen Sie.
Ja.
Aber wir wollen ja auch die Prüfung etwas simulieren.
Ja, ich werde die danke schön.
Gut.
Ja, sonst finde ich,
haben Sie das sehr ruhig und systematisch gemacht.
Ich denke, das ist für Sie auch ein gutes Training.
Wann haben Sie Prüfung?
Am Montag.
Wissen Sie denn, wie es letzte Woche gelaufen ist
beim letzten Tag?
Ja, Sie haben gestanden.
Sehr gut.
Ja, hallo Haike.